pour bonsoir ça lui a personne à
personne
c'est bien je vais disparaître un
instant est allé vérifier sur mes
réseaux que je vérifie aussi je reviens
la prof as tu des musiques qui m'ont je
me cache pour voir ma bière on n'a rien
vu alors on facebook sache le dha
fonctionne oui ça fonctionne ça ne
marche pas sur tout le monde avec ce son
si si ça marche
kim chapeau ça je me mets le poster sur
twitter mais a également raillé par tous
et normalement ça le bon titre
oui à mon gars c'est parce qu'on fait
que fois non moi je fais pas de quoi on
fait on fait un quiz d'abord et qu'est
ce qu'on gagne de lessines
yes bref le chapeau de robin qui c'est
parce que il ya mon casque en dessous en
fait c'est pas hyper compatible le sénat
dans le cadre a conduit et du coup c'est
triste tu as quoi quoi se dit juste que
je n'ai jamais eu ce ne revint pas ce
que je ne peux pas mettre mes évolué
dans le cadre à 100 les tenues mais les
sûretés et fo sur les épaules way allez
y lira ne tient pas ben c'est pas et
neuf personnes maintenant les gens
commencent à arriver soit hors dia par
jour pour jour à tout le monde
pas comme ça ça va les faire suivre
j'ai le feu en place et nous sommes sur
un live de pourparlers de paix noir avec
une partie de l'équipe 7 ce soir c'est
un live plutôt amusant et le 10e
répondre alors que nous en avait et on
verra c est sûr on va faire un quiz où
on parlera de peignoir que de mal à
entendre l'histoire
j'ai fait pareil que c'était sa
conférence assez drôle et moi aussi
finir la soirée seul un petit garde
faune dans le même thème pour s'amuser
l'oci et donc moi je suis là je suis
justin de france je suis la preuve c'est
moi qui ai écrit et irréaliste et noir
et je vais peut-être laisser se
présenter rapidement cher que
participants vont recevoir l'ordre
alphabétique ou comment puis je ne
m'abuse salut moi c'est clemi et je joue
lucrecia voilà il fallait donc
d'informations parfois combien dernier
la spa ou chauffer la dernière fois on
va faire assez à faire à pied je pense
non si on avait oublié en fait la
dernière fois et où et comment es tu toi
travailliste et moi la bombe
bonsoir pastry goût je joue la cyber
historienne et si vous nous donnez de
l'argent peut-être que j'aurai d'autres
personnes vous savez pas si vous donnez
de l'argent et bien peut-être je vais
jouer d'autres gens franchement si vous
voulez glaçons et qu'on est là nous vous
êtes des gens ça vaut le coup de faire
de bons jeux nous pourrons passer à
françois on oublie pas bonsoir moi c'est
je suis assistant réalisateur sur la
saison 2 de time warp si vous donnez de
là on va tous finir présentation comme
ça ça va super éléctro signe
astrologique france au scorpion et bien
au moins aussi aux le plot de twist
incroyables qui ont un qui sont accros
aux sms
ouais en parlant de l'année après est ce
qu'on arrive j'ai home games
salut moi c'est guillaume je joue le
barman et thierry l'agent de la super la
sorte dans la première saison et je
n'aurai aucun autre personnage dans la
saison 2 même si vous donnez de l'argent
que ça n'est pas le commentaire si vous
participez à notre aventure c'est plus
poli j'ai plus accepter de participer en
attendant qu à deux trois titres oui
bonjour moi je suis loué je ne joue pas
du tout je suis là chaque fois dans la
saison 2 si jamais vous partie par notre
aventure et que nous récoltons à cette
faune voilà mais non c'est bien bien
bien c'est un gros mot mais c'était et
nous terminons par robin oui bonjour et
bien dans la saison je joue et
l'inoubliable l'inoubliable passant
plainte
évidemment que tout le monde s'en
souvient pour ce rôle hyper important
neuf mois le préféré j'ai failli avoir
un oscar mais j'ai refusé parce que bon
un peu mais j'ai eu mes jeux surtout
fait la régie et dans la saison 2 se
serait ce que je fais si vous participez
à notre aventure
c'est à dire que vous pour ce week-end
comme ça là le principal
exactement parce que sinon ils vont être
tristes weeping en a qui aiment bien
manger beaucoup
donc voilà la grotte de viande a même
mais d'ailleurs on a déjà certains
membres qui ont fait des petites vidéos
promotionnelles aujourd'hui on a senti
celle de florence guillot si robin fcbe
qui ont fait des petites vidéos pour
témoin et guillaume qui en a peut-être
préparer une qui est alors environ
les chèques restaurants s'y mettra
d'ailleurs très bon très bon joueur très
très bons personnages en boîte on prend
les shaka soir oui tout à fait mais
chèques restaurant les diamants les
lingots d'or
les bijoux tous les bijoux anciens ce
que vous voulez mais il ya une question
oui mais j'ai vu d'un coup d'arrêt pour
la question qui fâche mais que se
passerait-il si l'objectif ulule n'avait
pas rempli saucier cela encore que le
projet ben on ya réfléchi on avoir
réfléchi à des solutions part du
principe que s'il le faut encore voir un
petit peu nos conditions à la baisse
niveau
niveau matériel nous tous à vos
accessoires costumes et donc que si on
approchait de l'objectif mais qu'on n'y
était pas totalement quelqu'un de
l'équipe mettrait le complément afin de
tous ces dons ne soit pas perdu et on
tournerait avec ce que vous auriez donné
mais là pour donc là pour l'instant on
est je peux l'affiché mêmes c'est
magique regardez on est à 2698 euros ce
qui est déjà pas mal donc plus de la
moitié plus de la moitié la mito
d'ailleurs je remets quand même le petit
niort une bulle n'hésitez pas à les
consulter si jamais vous découvrez alors
là que vous avez juste lui la portant à
9 n'hésitez pas à lui tout seul bien qui
apparaît sur leurs études ou et avec ta
souris justin est finie j'ai dit qu'est
ce que tu es doué avec ta souris tu as
tu fait afficher des trucs et tout
franchement c'est brillant manager peut
faire plusieurs choses en même temps
c'est vraiment très très bien
déjà je vois que c'est me dejean dans
les live ont abouti et j'ai mis des
fesses au fait et si non il n'y a pas
assez de fruits ils mangeront des pâtes
écouter tant pis très bien ces débats de
fond d'un silo franchement alors
j'aimerais mettre l'accent ch'ti qu'on
n'aura probablement aussi une grosse
partie la régie qui sera vg ce qui est
bien au moins vg qui ça fait mal parce
que c'est important et que ça coûte
moins cher mais qu'aussi c'est bien oui
et qu'on a pu prévoir mais j'ai
peut-être pour ceux qui n'existent pas
[Musique]
bon je pouvais bayer on a eu un jeu
tourne plus avec eux c'est ça le truc on
a eu un gros dos hier d'une association
d'histoire qui s'appelle le clio note
qui est une association de
de prof d'histoire et de géographie et
donc qui va tu es très sympathique et
qu'ils ont décidé de soutenir taille
noir bon ça déjà ça c'est une nouvelle
et une amie
on a aussi une proposition d'une
restauratrice de fournir dans quelques
reports donc ça s'est approché d'un
robot va être au chômage
beaucoup d'alliés déjà une journée du
championnat vasseur qui offre un repas
une anarchie enfin par son nom mais je
ferai le service de garde est ce que
j'espère que tu seras aux queues de pie
évidemment jamais pas assez de travail
pour le régisseur c est ce qu on fera
appel à des figurants pour la saison 2
il y aura qu elle ne figurant pas
énormément pour une scène pour une
soirée
lorsqu'après même pour ce qu'il était il
ya quelques personnages un peu
secondaire aussi mais beaucoup plus
qualifiés de silhouettes que de
figurants qu'ils ont quand même quelques
répliques ils sont plus présents mais ça
sera dans le nord je mettrai une annonce
toute façon si on voit là si on manque
de personnes parmi notre cercle de
poneys de connaissances et s'asseoir
quoi comment un quart lui créer une
annonce sur facebook et puis sur
d'autres relais donc vous serez informés
dit je suis désolée la pluie est en
train de tomber sur ma planche tomber
ton petit coup de boule et ma planche
voilà voilà une c'est super intéressant
est ce que on commencerait pas le quiz
ouais comme en voit pas le bordel fictif
est un con c'est nous alors ça peut être
vous ça peut être aussi les gens dans
les commentaires bien sûr s'ils ont une
réponse s'il connaît sa réponse
normalement j'ai pas pour les choses
trop compliquées
je propose qu'on lève la main c'est ce
qu' une petite est aussi que cela
prouvait un peu plus simple et dans ce
cas là je suis la seule à avoir les
réponses
même françois pour participer je l'aï
sentie si y'a que moi qui connais les
questions aussi d'ailleurs
on va faire ça pouvait lever la main que
je donne la parole comme
or ce rôle parce qu'en fait d'accord
jack daniel's à facebook ou aux jo et je
crois qu'on voit pas les questions
facebook ici est-ce qu'on peut pas vg
prendre un petit peu près comme ça je
pourrais noté mon coin c'est mieux s'il
ya du challenge quand même et on a des
fois des points cours pour les
spectateurs aussi de manière générale
les fondre une feuille vous avez vu les
moyens qu'on a quand même on a des
feuilles gros budget gros gros budget
pour ça qu'on a besoin d'argent
magnifique hymne tardis tout à fait oui
qu'il est magnifique et si vous avez des
questions dans les commentaires
n'hésitez pas une source éternelle merci
pour tes questions
mais si vous ne regardez que vous
demander des choses dans c'est quoi ta
mémoire c'est quoi cette saison 2 c'est
quoi ce lien réguler
bah vous n'hésitez pas et on vous répond
avec grand plaisir
on adore par les délégations parce que
sinon on doit trouver quoi dire c'est
dur déjà il ya des promos la caméra
devoir attendre
lamielle vraiment il ya beaucoup de deux
salles fight mais de façon en plus
l'ennemi a encore tué le game we avec sa
vidéo et on veut pas aller oscarisé on
peut plus rien faire
individuels et j'ai mis les spectateurs
en une seule équipe comme ça les
spectateurs vous êtes tous soudés et
facilement vaincre les participants je
vous avoue j'allais m échappe au chapeau
c'est la première question du queen's en
battant les jets sont tenues ce qui
motive rendement pour la saison 2 c'est
de vous retrouver tous ensemble oui et
de l'est oui et vraiment je le redis
encore une fois je vais déjà dit plein
de fois je suis cité dans les buts je
dois dû au premier life mais ça va être
génial si on peut faire cette saison
deux vraiment je serai l'homme le plus
heureux du monde
parce que savez ça va être très drôle ça
va être très fun va y avoir plein de
trucs intéressants plein développement
de personnages tant que nouveau
personnage est vraiment il faut que vous
nous donner des sous pour cela faire
circuler une autre question c'est quoi
ta mémoire que bien failli noir c'est
qu'une nouvelle série de science fiction
et d'humour qui se base sur les
personnages qui apparaissent
habituellement dans mes chroniques de
propre et d'autres personnages et qui
exporte des voyages dans des références
historiques et contenu parfois et c'est
drôle voilà oui et on a déjà fait la
saison us vous pouvez retrouver sur ma
chaîne youtube
or la saison 2 regardez il ya baby yoda
qui vous demandent de l'argent
et blanc c'est la première question est
ce que nous a tous fait
oui oui alors donc on s'y tient à
laurence chaves a aussi dit laurence
parent dont florence très grave
j'aimerais simplement c'est pour ça que
j'ai confondu par catherine muller n'a
du coup oui lui donne la balle
il ya des questions qui sont soulevées
sur les voyages en temps tu doives ses
fils deux agents tant aux coûts des
questions d'histoire et des questions
telles marques qui sont en tout genre
est ce que vous êtes prêts oui oui de
très près
on suppose il ya bien deux et combien de
latence avec même pas beaucoup je vous
prends anormalement pourrait vraiment
pas d'ennemis normalement c'est pas trop
utiliser les héros voyager dans le passé
pour se retrouver en pleine guerre de
cent ans dans quel film l'est et au
voyage qui est dans le passé pour se
retrouver en pleine guerre de cent ans
c'est un film pas hyper connue mais que
kevin et qui est tirée vin est tiré d'un
livre écrit par le même cas que jurassic
park
alors alors moi j'ai l'auteur mais ça ne
va pas nous aider à chercher sur
wikipédia ou pas non pas pour le
fédéraux la question pour un champion
excusez moi je peux chercher sur mon
téléphone julien leurs accessoires
oui il y en a fait depuis sa fenêtre et
je viens donner du fil hauteur c'est
michael crichton tout à fait et non pas
l'expéditeur celle inverse ils viennent
sur ces termes elle a une réponse c'est
pas ça va venir sans lui dit oui on y
est presque une petite faute d'un titre
eh ben je tombe nez à nez avec de
l'aisne prisonniers oui eh bien c'est un
poids pour les spectateurs
on va se faire ouvrir parce que on peut
pas arriver ils vont sur wikipédia avant
les bons joueurs l'échappée soyez bons
choix saillon bon quoi vous aurez
sûrement un avantage pour la question
c'est quoi alors vous avez droit à
plusieurs réponses combien de temps a
duré du clemi en première demie en
première et en même temps bah il ya 50
ans parce que j se bagarrer que l'était
pas l'hiver c'est notre seul qui a eu le
dessus et donc j'ai misé ces gens
[Musique]
m'avaient dit qu'ils combattaient pas
l'hiver est du coup passée ça faisait
s'entend mais ç'a duré que 50 ans du
coup parce que c'est moi si oui mais on
dit que c'était quand même en guerre
c'est juste qu'ils se battaient pas mais
c'était comme à la guerre c'est l'énoncé
et pepa quoi y avait confusion mois
et même 2h30
je sais pas si je voyage dans le temps
donc je peux savoir
il y avait une question de l est là l
amdh a été demandée sont pas jouées à
partir du 2 tweets ch oui tout à fait on
voit les commentaires sur youtube nous
dit oui ça fait longtemps qu'on attend a
lille on a les dieux combien de caisse
de quel siècle
bon allez du 15 et du coup c'est
impossible
non ça dépend où s'achève lé nord est
pour gueule même en tête comme ça ah je
sais c'est en bourgogne à lui oui mais
lorsque la guerre de cent ans ça se
termine comme ça je m'en souvenais plus
exact je sais combien tu sais exactement
combien dans sa durée mais tu sais pas
quand ça a commencé avec ans a terminé à
oui parce que c'est ça qui est rigolo
c'est de savoir que la gare de santal et
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour les
questions de santé
quelle est la date de naissance
d'aliénor et d'où vient-elle également
semble-t-il eu dans ce que j'ai inventé
sur elle en vaut elle est née au début
du 15ème siècle commence à inventer non
immersion qu'elle était au début du
xvème siècle elle
ses parents sont travail à la cour du
ville de north one donc d'en dehors de
la france
ce que l'équipe de google était à
présent dans le nord de la france à
cette époque vous avez en partie du
territoire et donc voilà les issues de l
est pas la noblesse
mais depuis il ya un ami max ce mix am3
qui dit que ces deux traits 137 à 14,150
3 merci c'est ça j'étais près 450 de 453
en même temps que la chute de
constantinople si je ne me trompe pas
exactement alors % d'historiens dans ce
dans ce live deux et demi cela fait six
ans
2/5 rabat c'est pour ça je pouvais pas
savoir moi je me suis arrêté au cm2
voilà la question suivante il faut être
attentif
elle n'est pas compliqué mais possible
ils lucrecia à deux grappes de raisin
comprenant chacune 25 20 et la manche 3
sur la première et deux sur la deuxième
parce qu'elle n'a pas très fin et
qu'elle est un peu chiante sélectif de
raison en chiffres romains et se plaît à
de raisin contenant chacune un malaise
là je ne propose elle ne mange pas sur
la première et deux sur la deuxième on
vient on vers sept-îles en chiffres
romains qui est vraiment excellent
oui mais ça c'est tout allait bien
compris ce jeu qu'à dix ans premier
entre le chat et moi madonna prend un
coup de main oui bloquer à crolles
l'exécutent chatte
oui beaucoup sur cette question là ok
parce que sinon il y en a 45 maghnia
demande encore si sur les chapeaux de
roue ça fait quarante élèves et ensuite
pour ça j'espère qu'on attendait le le
rsa vous pourquoi le lcm et xl bas il
fait du coup quand même ça fait 40 ans
que v ça fait quand on sait qu'en mai
1 1 avant le spectacle était bien avant
le elle nous nous en fait quand tu mets
un une lettre avant une lettre ça retire
la somme donc l xl pardon ça fait
cinquante au moins le cas
et quand tu mets levée après ça rajoute
la somme donc c'est qu'on a fait on a 40
puissante on voit la preuve en plus
grand
j'ai envie terrible sa crue c'est romain
je pensais que ça et ce stade ça ne
marchait que pour les uns et non pas les
loups n'ont croisé x est pas trompé
excusez moi je veux pas rentrer dans le
débat mais paraît-il que ça va
disparaître les chiffres romains et
convenant jacques rire avec lui c'est
trop compliqué bon très bon mais pas
trop compliqué oui moi même à tort un
petit peu c'est juste moi qui suis con
au choix bouhlel 50 c'est pas évident
après donc les quatre premiers mois
l'habitude quoi jusqu'à 20 accès facile
mais après mon et si seulement jamais
qu'à des coûts a personnellement
d'apprendre que le 50 c'était elle
ce soir là avec vous on apprend des
choses ici c'est ça qui est beau à
premiers chiffres romains avec la prod
doute de rien alors du coup question
suivante dans doctor who à laquelle
rennes le docteur at il eu une aventure
et son coin jarry bm qui alternant les à
mettre au moins tout à fait dans un
épisode spécial
il s'était dans le spécial 50 ans
s'affaire l'espèce
avec le war docteur de noël non c'est
non je crois que c'est le 50 ans je
crois bon c'est celui avec vous attend
oui non attends quoi sert avec david
tonon n'y a pas d'aspect haïti il ya
bien ceci carrément parce que ça laisse
un goût de quoi causer pompadour le chat
s'était passé mais il n'a pas une
aventure au royaume et pompadour schilb
avec les cheminées là non elle a même
confié que c'est le solide et 50 ans
voilà les du coûteux conseil fixe sévit
dans cette voie c'est la vie alors
est-ce que vous êtes prêts mais pour
l'instant on a trois mois pour le
spectateur est important enfin pour
françois info guillaume citer le nom
d'un duc de bourgogne si vous en citer
vieux vous avez deux mains si vous les
citer tous dans leur vaudrait son coin
un essai des questions non non non moi
mais justin pourquoi tu fais un millier
[Musique]
le jeu apparaît l'image
à bonn ya bien pendant ya pas un
philippe lebon dedans tout à fait et
bien c'est un peu comme au vin yes
j'aime bien la réponse de polo juste
peschard chat on a déjà une réponse du
coup on va rester sur la réponse de
plusieurs balles à yanick jean claude
thin ont été réduits proposés comme un
mirage
je vais préparer des pompiers tpourquoi
vu que c'est un rituel sur cette image
mais j'aime bien que par une image
ensuite elle rit parce qu'elle y est non
je ne comprends pas le méchant sans tom
sykes a compté aussi je crois oui
effectivement
oui j'avais dit parce qu'elle vient de
comprendre calais nord et godefroy vont
faire des enfants
là oui c'est vrai ah oui c'est un
bêtisier c'est encore plus drôle mais
bon du coup bas pas de quoi donc les
jeux les apps est la suivante vous allez
encore dire que non mais je dis et j'ai
vu un point c'était bien mais mais du
coup c'est à nouveau une question
historique un peu s'il ressemble ce
qu'on n'a pas une interview d'interviews
de lucrecia comment s'appelle le roi de
france qui succède à vendre et 4 et 5
c'est par richard
ce n'est pas normal dans le métro à
winnezeele maîtresse mais oui tu as
raison loup c'est le premier rendez vous
je suis vraiment content c'est un
compliment peuple t'a vu ton shakur mis
les buts et j'adore mais je prends ça
comme un compliment
ah ouais pas mal comme ça et kevin est
ce un an mais j'ai trop besoin de
plonger la version de lucrecia mais en
steampunk alors dans retour vers le
futur comment s'appelle le chien alors
lequel parce qu'il y en a de trop bas
ab c'est lourd c'est luc et moi j'avais
vu loup en premier que j'ai la main moi
j'ai vu moi mais bon répondu un peu
spectateur et tout le monde a défendu on
a un chien est en vrai je pense que l'on
devrait avoir un point en plus pour il
ya deux chiens déjà merci source
éternelle pour ce jeu de mots
incroyables charles ban toi tu peux
participer au projet aux abonnés il
était d'ailleurs on est toujours on est
toujours à 2698 il me semble bayeux 10
euros plus c'était de 1788
alors est-ce qu'on peut atteindre les
2800 ce soir quand même il faut aller
3000 à l'e3
la passerelle moins un million à venir
la highway alors de la tête à côté
les repas de du mal qui honnit d'aider
le restaurant clandestins là il y aura
que de la truffe
aussi nous mettre des gros blocs de
pierre géant challans sergent sacrée
pierre vidal et tu peu importe que ce
soit sur twitter et youtube on te voit
de toute façon je regarderai 804 a envie
de voir les autres gens sur youtube qui
convoite pour les commentaires à la fois
sentir moins alors question suivante
qu'est-ce que la brigade temporel c'est
pas un livre de robert gbian premier oui
brigade temporel c'est la police qui
empêche les gens de voyager dans le
temps et l'histoire du futur ouais moi
aussi j'y crois pas trop du temps une
des villas mais on a une question du
chat mais genre mode sans quiz pour nous
est ce que vous savez comment est mort
louis 3 quant à lille il allait prendre
son bain dans la rivière mais il a gardé
son armure et il témoigné
je pense que ça glisse alors watchers
tth pas les gens qui s'est pris gens
râlent un taux de port je pense que
voilà celui qui s'était tué par un
cochon non y'en a qui est mort alors je
sais pas c'est très je suis pas sûr de
pouvoir le dire en live ça mais bon
c'est bon quasi non mais jan ake mort en
se brûlant entre comme ça non juste un
président qui est mort pendant la chose
avec sa maîtresse oui c'est qui je sais
son nom je voulais être pas saisir il
finit par lui et le linteau de porte
sont à 2 pour le coup il ya louis valois
et charleville je crois donc c'était
bien là d'un taux de court voilà bon
bien joué quid si on peut dire que les
l'impôt de porsche ont tué deux fois
plus de roi de france que la guillotine
c'est vrai oui c'est l'export fort il
était fort la réponse la réponse pour
louis iii s'était il a poursuivi une
fille qui voulait dans son lit mais il
sert eto'o mais la tête dans la poutre
d'une porsche
voilà alors une tombe qui l'a porté au
real par bah voilà est rentré à cheval
dans une porte c'est difficile oui césar
et pompée je me disais bien je mets le
matière de médecine la bande
d'historiens qu'on fait ça va on a
presque dit encore de temps en temps
j'ai encore une question alors que vous
que voix astrid lorsqu'elle rencontre à
l'énorme électriciens en vrai ou
[Musique]
pour 2000 et de la faune sauvage et
différences levé la main en premier ce
n'est pas si étonnant pourpre et les
spectateurs du rhum
d'après les bandes ni d'ailleurs de
l'acier avec quelques gouttes de rome
on avait mal comme ça moi bah en fait je
voulais pas dis pas ce que je voulais
c'était voilà nos skis point spectateurs
d'élèves qui durera du roi mettant fin
du dieu aux knicks d'ailleurs du dieu
unique et c'est pas moi qui avait ramené
cette bouteille je sais plus où elle
venait c'était pas une bouteille du
boire non sens évident
ouais c'est pas moi j'avais pas devant
chez moi on passe avec moi ont
clairement que j'adore voir du rhum je
précise sachez le chef il faut consommer
de l'alcool avec modération et c'est moi
qui dit ça en tant que barman
mais cette gaffe demandons nous avons
bien placé pour le savoir mieux justin
mieux non je parle à justine d'accord
mais comme ça non c'est toi qui as tu un
grand la main et ben voilà maintenant je
peux dire s'il atteint les 2800 à bercy
pour lui et moi j'aimerais chapeau dans
l'hébétude là c'est déjà ça alors
pendant ses cours à rarement qu'ils
demandent c'est qu'ils modération
c'était la voix dans ta tête tu dis est
ce que c'est une barre de trop oui ça
c'est modération un jeu après quelques
questions parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
sinon il faut dit que on a le temps oui
on a le temps mais après il ya un an
partis au quiz vous n'êtes pas prêts
pour ça continue encore
littéralement en quel siècle est inventé
la fourchette tard ainsi est abondante
la vue de tous qui a levé la main en
premier mais vous dénoncez pas si on
pourra les robes allez on va dire que
oui parce qu'elle a pas encore de point
famille je vous donne la parole après je
vais dire aux bills xiième siècle et ces
[Rires]
derniers mois furent donnés mes poules
oh c'est trop mignon
[Musique]
la section des réponses sur lui
christian bataille n'est pas la faute
aux questions que je fasse moi j'aurais
dit j'aurais dit qu'on allait bien mais
ça n'est pas exact
j'ai vérifié et c'est tout oui
non non non non je sais quand même ce
n'est pas non plus le quatrième siècle
ça n'est pas non plus le 37e siècle ni
le 17e
je dirais en même genre un peu à la
renaissance 16e alors ça a été pas alors
un de ces sièges et ça se dit finalement
ça ouais on se dira donc ce n'est pas si
mauvais comme réponse mais c'est un peu
la date de l'invention du coût 15
il y avait l'histoire reprises évoquant
justement découvert en or du ferro bord
j'essaie de montrer que les mines et
j'irai son diagonale dormait reverser la
question dans l'est en france ou dans le
monde de la deux du monde entier dit en
11e siècle non sur média mexique
encore considéré ou aligné une onzième
siècle donc ça veut dire que ça date
d'avant la fourchette comme on l'entend
de manière moderne écoute sur wikipédia
du 8ème 9ème siècle et s'est fait un peu
défaut chez vous pouvez pas des
fourchettes
il ya un peu pas que moi qui trichent
visible le boss caution peut compter
laiteries dont pourrait du coup vous
voulez savoir
ça n'a rien à voir intelligent par
contre possédant il n'a pas existé
excusez moi super blasphème prendrais tu
le vois bien pourquoi tu dis ça c'est
pas poséidon du tout bon ok c'est né de
deux minutes après son entrée dans la
salle ils ont tout copier les romains du
coup je laisse tomber les points pour la
question même fourchette
c'est pour deux raisons tout le monde à
aller
non j'avais le bon siècle voilà
dans quel nom quel personnage a vécu à
l'époque la plus ancienne au maire
remercie monsieur c'est que les milliers
de la première je répondis bon maire oui
alors alors se permettre une aisance
avait pas une personne c'est un titre il
est au bilan dans ta chemise rose à
ronger 16h10 prieur toi merde bien 16h08
c'est le premier jockey bombe à la
sénatrice maire a vraiment existé
voilà c'est ce que j'allais dire c'est
ça le vrai débat qu'on m'enlève mon
poids des lobbys c'est en tout cas du
viiie siècle puisque c'est lui qui fait
le titre mais c'est le premier importe
de se sont mis d'accord inclus ça fait
littéralement cela il ya tellement de
strips 4 que son nom devient un titre la
péter avec le peu de connaissances que
j'ai en histoire c'était juste pour me
la clarté si l'on regardé la série rome
ça résume très bien la balle et ce alors
que moi quand même
vraiment s'il y avait une mineure dans
le tchat
bon c'est particulier on ne regardait
pas ni spartacus ni rome parce que il ya
du sang mais aussi non à lézignan c'est
bien et prend sans même regarder à une
question du chat j'aime beaucoup ça que
trouve-t-on dans la mine de sel de 10
villes escales près de cracovie en
pologne
moi je pense qu'on trouve de l'or des
[Musique]
polonais a peut-être un dragon du
maîtrise notamment de la véraison du sel
c'est aller un point pour nous
je vais regarder un essai trop beau
franchement allez allez voir sur
à ces magnifiques pouvoir dire et alors
on dirait un peu les trucs en glace en
plus des pc incroyable merci pour
l'anecdote
ouais mais j'ai beaucoup ohlala mais
quelle olala mais c'est incroyable
voilà maintenant il faut alors moi
mesdames et messieurs je vais devoir
vous laisser pour raisons personnelles
des abonnés
[Musique]
bah je les donne
aléatoirement à lou sait pas si c'est
une bonne soirée merci le chat d'être là
de nous faire rire de nous poser des
questions et de donner des sous de
participer à cette aventure pardon et je
vous souhaite une très bonne fin de
soirée
oui mais pas durant la prochaine
question du tout alors attendez parce
qu'il ya deux choses dans le tchat
déjà il ya georges qui nous dit bonsoir
bonsoir jauge et il ya une très bon jeu
donné de source éternelle qui dit dadis
était salée pour la construction de
quatre années ça ne pouvait pas rester
ignorée je suis désolé c était très
bonne excuse pas aimer du coup la
cathédrale notre dame de paris ont pour
l art in over ans elle ça serait moins
cher peut-être placé dans le ciel de
traîne assez l'abri de la pluie je crois
ouais c'est ça parce que s'il pleut ça
va mieux alors attention itélé passant
de l'épisode 3 de la saison une de pie
noire soit les comédiens soient les
personnages vous pouvez chacun à
répondre si vous n'avez pas forcément je
crois que c'est florence mais je suis
pas sûr
j'hésite entre loups et moi moi j'ai
hésité entre florence et françois pas
super la défense est alors la royaliste
le patient plainte d'aig dans son propre
rôle
[Rires]
alors absolument où tu vois pas ce que
ça voulait dire une bêtise alors qu'elle
allait alors je l'essayé cours de maths
après la difficulté d'un l'ordre dans
lequel on les voit dans l'épisode alors
jihad là avec la fille qu'on voit
vraiment au tout début
intitulé la face on vénère voilà aliénor
c'est une passante en soi et elle passe
dans la rue ensuite la pala royalistes
alors une épée dans l'ordre ah bon bah
non mais il ya moi mais je suis pas dans
le genre la difficulté et ses adeptes
il ya le script il ya juste un an
voilà il ya à tanger 10 qui jadis kimia
ii aliénor dave neary qu'est ce que je
peux donner c'est pas moi non magique
heures du matin il a été dit oui à la
robin h n'est pas dit non non c'est un
vin mais c'est pas moi ouais robin c'est
durant cette plainte à temps et est en
médiane oui c'est moi mais du coup c'est
la royale soit en premier pour moi la
séquence avait été la séquence avec les
gens à mais non parce que c'est
d'arriver et justin qui sont après parce
qu'après justement ça c'est un truc où
c'est un peu switch which sa sweep
as tu en fais ton truc je vérifie pas ce
que ça va me rendre à savoir une fois
que cette histoire j'ai désolé je suis
relou dans son landau truc ça va me
prendre la tête
asie continue et c'est une question
qu'on va en tirer
[Musique]
où se trouve à syrte autre fois à la fin
de la saison une de payement celica
poser la question alors il se trouve en
venise et ça plus tout à fait à dire les
crocs à venise en italie et ça schlingue
oui différencie vous développerez
scission d'ailleurs qui dit qu' on est
pas de vianne c'est la façon donc et je
n'avais pas la télé point d'ailleurs
pour précédemment me dire que florence
est lourd et d'écouter les ans avec
décote que la chaîne arraï âgées dans le
temps de jeu de boules a décidé resto
rien quel parfum doux et aux ancêtres
et comme les anciennes photos tirées et
ea j'avais raison c'est la royaliste son
premier ça n'aura pas servi à rien mais
je maintiens medef dans son propre rôle
ouais mais oui je connais juste exercice
dans la saison deux bailleurs et
d'autres ailleurs mais rien d'aussi
d'ailleurs et iront aussi
là tout le monde cuisine bien c'est ça
qui est beau voilà il va probablement
aussi déjà dégoûté voilà quelques
champignons
c'était ce qu'il fallait rafa mais là
c'est d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à
participer ou ellul dans le lien
satisfaisant de scoop je voir mourir
pour la saison 2 de la noire est aussi
accessoirement médiéval au vaste de des
traits de tanger papa nourriture mais
c'est très peu mais bon c'est pas tout
ça
il est vrai que c'est une nouvelle
question est en fait je pense qu'on
pourra passer la deuxième partie déjà
pas mal de questions quelle est la
réplique préférée du dixième docteur oui
alonso jeudi avant le contenu ça mais
oui mais moi même je t'ai pas vu lever
la main en fait il y en chatte quel
oiseau trouve-t-on sur le drapeau de la
papouasie nouvelle guinée je dirais un
kiwi aphrodite rire peut-être une autre
à temps un oiseau un pays ami moudre et
rauque et gentil bref banon geronimo
c'est le mondial des cadets mios et
chair d'animaux chiens précis il vous
plait il sait pas allons-y alone aux os
et allons-y alonso la percée des fautes
de frappe
je pense que c'est une faute de frein a
pris 0 il a dans un ruisseau du cool
la plupart du temps et du talent
oui c'est bon là je ne sais pas j'ai
jamais regarder dr où a commencé la
critique un cadre dans le temps les gens
d'où la wii les gens en général oui j'ai
pas vu et je le sais c'est la cultive à
sion 1 2 et le géant retransmettra tu
vas découvrir l'incroyable en fait j'ai
bien compris et c'est pas lutter rocher
de bakwa pas l'accrocher gpat un dossier
a doctor who
jojo je suis loin en plus il toujours
pas l'intellect et j'y arrive pas voilà
tu peux pas être mais tu as comme un
second celui d'avant tenait à lui a
peut-être 100
c'est une blague la fille est la copine
là tu sentais qu'ils cherchent un peu
quoi mais nombreux et après ça ne c'est
pas pour toi c'est pas en plus je sais
ça me laisse des trucs mais tant pis
alors que j'ai le drapeau de la
papouasie nouvelle guinée devant les
yeux elle sait pas ce que c'est comme
oiseau de paradis une très bonne quatre
matches connaissez le burger quiz et non
un burger king
je n'ai pas que nous avons un quiz il
faudra répondre soit avant soit d'autre
soit les deux et bien voilà et noir du
général de gaulle pas mal ok ok très
différents ce qui se crée
les personnages doivent résoudre un
conflit armé les deux alors comme j'ai
vu regard a permis de faire de la france
du général de gaulle non pas sur la
saison en 2000 à leicester jeu juste
autant on va minutes on a eu deux autres
dont tu vois je propose qu'on les
remercie aussi merci à thomas nos bars
pour sa participation et mercian
d'arvant bart van d'une c'est quoi comme
ça se prononce
merci beaucoup pour tes jours puis
d'avoir participé à cette aventure
voilà les remercie pour les toros est
trop gentil sonabel comment par la
france du général de gaulle ah oui un
grand fan du petit quiz des personnages
voyagent dans le temps et avoir tout à
fait et c'est gratuit
date de naissance qui serait ainsi le
josé huleux panique et non les gens tous
les pontes de gaulle désolé ce n'est pas
question suivante ce sont surtout les
femmes qui sont importantes
quand même toit la boule noire s'était
pas encore ça j'essaie parle du nouveau
c'est quoi qui est important les femmes
les familles c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave je te plaît nouveau personnage
dans la saison 2 mais encore
sauf si peu et de l'étude mais quid de
la saison 2 de la française de football
[Musique]
pour dire si vous y accompagneront être
aventure c'est encore plus à mal mal
mais bon ici attention à ce que vous
êtes prêt un personnage se retire à
colombey les deux églises
la france du général de gaulle
j'adore ces blagues et j'adore je joue
alors un personnage revient sur sa
décision après avoir compris les
revendications de ses compatriotes la
france du général de gaulle
non ce n'est pas une bonne réponse rémy
with françois les deux les deux
mais ne faisons pas d'accord si y avoir
là l'historienne elle revient sur ses
décisions enfin compris les enjeux et
des revendications
emilie et où william est perçue en
allemagne et de la france du général de
gaulle à bord similitudes
est-ce que tu ne comparera le personnage
que je joue à de gaulle parce que je ne
suis pas sûre de son bon droit
soyons clairs je vais remettre un peu le
lien et je passe à la question suivante
attention ça peut être compliqué un
personnage comme des champignons au
xvème siècle n'a pas encore une fois
j'ai vu qu'on soit en premier mais juste
après le point de vue que fait lille
c'est pas du coup qu'il avait la main en
premier j'avais tellement français se la
joue très bien ma disons très bien bon
ba ty warp ans ne s'est pas avoir tout à
fait ah oui amazon un peu à bamako des
étudiants se révoltent contre l'ordre
établi à bâle âgées mais franchement je
pense que je pense que c'est françois
louw de la france du général de gaulle
et françois voilà alors on a une
question dans le chat est ce que gros
goût fera t-il partie de la saison 2 non
ce n'est on à l est de voir avec disney
on les a contactés ils nous ont pas
répondu partie de saison de demande
alors rien probablement probablement
dans le challenge serait s'il veut y
contribuer
[Rires]
oui à des janissaires oui bah bien son
nom mais ces ados que j'ai vu je parle
[Rires]
non j'ai demandé si la fin de la saison
2 du monde à lorient il se passe un truc
absurde pour savoir si je l'avais vu ou
pas pas si c'était la saison 2 où l'a1 à
laquelle je pense il se passe aussi un
autre cadeau qui se passe à la fin de la
saison deux thèmes à teesside questions
suivantes attention des personnages mon
recours aux assassinats pour courir ma
connerie de temps à moi j'ai besoin de
précisions qu'est ce que c'est toujours
chez ovale juillet où est il le font pas
bon mais les deux les deux les deux mais
sachant que c'est là d'autres
personnages qui venaient d'autres
époques
pétillon disque avec une telle assertion
que les agents de la mairie fin de
rencontre et donc des deux descentes
dans le tchad qui ont eu les deux ans la
pire la clé rade le dégoût que tous les
autres sont morts
oui c'est vrai je le dis ouais j'aime
bien la menteuse
connais mieux ah bah je savais qu'il
disait mais après on sait ce que tu dis
là c'est comme si la monteuse avait vu
les mêmes images pleins de fois de suite
en boucle en boucle alors la nuit
incroyable je vous rappelle que quand je
faisais du montage à la et on enchaîne
et de droite
j'ai vu françois la france du général de
gaulle et c'est la force du général de
gaulle bien joué la prochaine c'est un
peu plus appel à vos connaissances
historiques
le début de l'histoire se passe dans le
nord de la france bat romain qui a levé
la main baladeuse les deux et pourquoi
les deux bas parce que le général de
gaulle est né à lille où ta clé est que
le début de taymor ça se passe dans le
nord de la france tout à fait bien jouer
à voir le début elle est née à ville
d'ailleurs il ya des plans de ma famille
il ya longtemps qu'ils étaient les
voisins de de gaulle a dans sa maison
natale et dans sa maison juste après et
apparemment dans une de ses biographies
et parle de en dix ans qui se souvient
de ses voisins ou brouillon et s est ce
que du coup il disait que il faisait
trop de bruit de gaulle quand il est des
soirées étudiantes ou des trucs comme ça
je sais pas que j'aurai donc fait sur
les démon de midi de minuit le truc
comme ça
l'américaine du connemara vous n'avez
séquence il était enfant je sais parfois
je regarde elle viendra fils et quelle
histoire
le palais source
les chroniques palais font ces questions
suivantes attention un personnage
dissous l'assemblée nationale
j'ai mis la france du général de gaulle
bien joué qu'elle est également experte
mes impressions parce que si nous des
questions sur la france parce que c'est
parce que je suis mal écrit c'est parce
que justin a écrit la france du général
de gaulle avant d'écrire taymor
compétition c'était la première de ça
j'ai jamais un personnage se prend un
coup de place je sais pas de vue en même
temps du mot bataille moi et moi tout à
fait bien fait ça moi on sait pas
d'ailleurs on a filmé le plan mais on
n'a jamais lâché
alors franchement j'ai écouté avec les
deux mais disons que comme comme c'est
moi qui fut beaucoup de plaintes ce jeu
voilà il ya probablement un tel cas où
la france du général de gaulle qui s'est
pris un coup plainte mais ouais de mai
alors n'hésitez pas mon coup de plaintes
et du coup ça nasdaq ça n'existe pas je
tiens à dire que je m'en suis bien remis
en tout cas ça va pas trop de séquelles
sur le compath c'est fait je pense est
content on parle de gaulle avec ses
potes de saint cyr faisait la pièce pas
ouais mais je crois pas que c'était à
l'époque où il était à saint cyr puisque
bas ça se passait à lui quand il était
voisin de des gens à ce qui faisait des
karaokés sur la tribu de dana
parce qu'à la fin moi je pense que c'est
pas vrai parce que est pas la chanson
n'était pas encore sorti parce qu'elles
datent des années 90 et c'est un point
pour clubic sorte un dentier j 1 points
en plus ou non de bienne ont très bien
c'est une chance
alors l'un des personnages principaux
faits de la vulgarisation historique sur
youtube
je crois que c'est florence haye voir sa
taille noir tout à fait florence pendant
la france du général de gaulle youtube
c'est pour ça que j'ai précisé youtube
jeu juste il compterait rue et dernière
question dans cette catégorie attention
il ya une saison 2
pourquoi florence a été la première
encore une fois collé pas réponse oui
moi ce n'est pas mon enfance c'est les 2
c les deux puisque de gaulle a été réélu
et oui ok bah ouais d'accord c'est vrai
alors est-ce que vous tournez dévolu
pour franck il ya effectivement il ya
encore une saison 2
y a pas encore eu mais il y en aura une
pour l'instant et si vous participez à
notre aventure on pourra la faire avec
un budget plus intéressant et on pourra
se nourrir alors n'hésitez pas à
continuer de contribuer avec le lien qui
se trouve juste en dessous des biens de
ben on est toujours le vérifier on est
toujours là est ce que vous voulez qu'on
continue parce que maintenant je peux
vous proposer un duel de citations de
gaulle ou time warp peut pas sur le
garde faune comme comme vous préférez
comme le chat tu préfères les deux et
c'est un point fort au graff yes y en a
beaucoup parlé gestion y en a beaucoup
mais je peux en appel bon pour faire
quelques unes à les présenter sous une
haie puis aux lentilles
encore quelques minutes de questions
attention je connais les voitures
j'étais juste pas prête pour les
tracteurs s'éclairicie on parle j'ai vu
d'où un parfait allié nord qui dit ça et
pas voir tout à fait bien jouer je suis
un monarchiste la république n'est pas
le régime qu'il faut à la france
j'ai pas vu dans un billet wallonne tous
ensemble de façon je pense que c'est
facile parce que cette année tu peux
répéter
non je n'ai pas moi je suis un
monarchiste la république n'est pas le
régime qu'il faut à la france bat la
france du général de gaulle 1 et de
gaulle tout à fait mais mme aigner ça
pourrait être un spoiler de la saison 2
time warp couleurs de la saison 2 c'est
pour ça que j'ai hésité pendant un
instant je me suis dit mais non elle
aura pas miser sur la coupe
maintenant ça reste intéressant du coup
par exemple j'ai pas l'habitude de
torture et les gens et me canoy
les deux auraient pu être les deux
médecins un mot pour mot bah y'a
sûrement quelqu'un pendant la france du
général de gaulle cali qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude s'est décidé à céder citation
de de gaulle même je prends donc on
devrait maintenant est désolé ok ok les
français sont des faux ok je vais dire
la france du général de gaulle -6 me
semble non lalas aux rails personnes
disent ah ok
qui pourrait presque être pour les deux
vous m'expliquer ce qui se passe et si
je peux vous aider je le fais c'est time
world et c'est la prof qui dit ça et
c'est dans ma cave bizarre période
l'algérie avec la avec la la la la cave
avec la lumière qui s'éteint tout tout
seul tous les cinq minutes extrêmement
violents et donc tu as hâte d'atteindre
et voilà que je me plains pas si c'est
drôle ça m'était du piment dans le
tourmalet et qu il était bien là
hirvonen dans les commentaires alors je
ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais du coup
elle elle est pas mal mais comment
voulez vous qu'elle 66 ans j'entame une
carrière de dictateur
c'est vrai qu'on a mal mais ces
continents son nom 7 degrés
franchement c'est possible qu'il ait dit
me suit c'est vrai on a je ne vais pas
mal mais rassurez vous un jour ne manqua
pas de mourir je sais pas qui a levé la
saisie grâce à ses 2 go le dégoût et
effectivement il a tenu ses promesses
comme un bon président et oui il est
mort effectivement c'est effectivement
sur ses éternels là où william a failli
mourir là où guillaume a failli mener un
contre lillois
oui miel forces de la kfor mort te
pourrir pour les trois lacs
le général de gaulle oui tout à fait bah
je pense qu'on peut jeudi les deux
rivaux l'offre parce qu'on a faites sans
presser sur le quartier phone allez y
les plus touchés car vieux malades peau
mais peut-être que ça embête pour le
garde faune en ce que tu es fatigué tu
peux y aller si tu veux quand même
si avec moi après deux passes ça vous va
et alors j'ai envie de manger un bon là
j'essaie quand on aura les sous y'a pas
de manger avant c'est aujourd'hui c'est
après la pause que quelques petites
parties de cartes piétonnes pour finir
la soirée
l'antarctique je vais vous envoyer un
lien abstention les le mettre sur sur
facebook que sur messenger
normalement la science est bon françois
le renvoyer chez lui fin c'est moi mais
je suis sûr c'est moi qui l'ait envoyé
d'accord parfait et moi je vais faire un
partage d'écran pour que les spectateurs
voient ma partie de bertic phone non non
normalement les spectateurs voilà ma
partie oui pas de changer dans la dans
le truc genre je sais pas si tu peux une
fois que c'est lancé live mail twitch il
faudrait en attend que françois hallé
françois ya of words rubilar son frère
jonathan
pour l'instant j'en laisse la flemme
mini là ouais on attend que françois
nebout rejoignent et ouais non je vais
avoir du mal à changer parce que c'est
sur l'autre hors dit c'est pas grave on
va rester sur la stratégie numérique
je vais pas pouvoir parler pendant
graphique fans parce que je ne peux pas
mieux ou telle micro retourner sur la
page du gard tic tout ça n'a pas marché
mais je pense que c'est possible
il ne manque le françois pour le gard
tic nous sommes en attente de l'hôte
il est là oui je suis là mais on attend
françois web island à françois oui
messieurs regardiez je veux dire à
françois on n'entend pas maintenant je
m'écroulais mais je pense que c'est fou
hein technologie de python et ça marche
alors il faut penser à ces thèmes là du
coup mince way we were les faux pas des
trucs trop peur chez nous plus que s'ils
n'ont vraiment jamais trouvé à temps
mais faut que ça soit des six nabeul si
on aramon 0 idée simple il a dû val d'or
ok tout le monde est là je vais mettre
le partage d'écran et du coup je crois
qu'on regarde ton écran parce que sinon
on voit ce que tu as marre oui on va
être bien république mais là trop déjà
ok j'ai eu l'idée de faire des trucs
qu'ils soient voyage longtemps pas et
moi faire trés bastion enfin aussi si on
n'a pas d'idée dans ce tableau pour
faire autre chose on est plutôt libre
moi j'ai mis un truc style et je suis
fier de moi j'ai pas aimé garder quoi y
perdre qu'est ce que ce soit tombé sur
moi ou pas je l'aïe là comme ça ça me va
n importe quoi on dit le caravage
je m'excuse 1 pour la perche pas de
graphistes berne ouvre aux
malraux se moquait pas graphie parce
qu'il ya à quai par un film est là sinon
bravo voilà là à temps comment on efface
faire contrôler les aides aux ce
fait j'ai la moitié du temps
[Musique]
c'est comme ça comme ça vient
alors ça va être le mot de vérité et
remplir avec ce que ça marche ou pas yes
et non ça s'est passé mais j'ai fini de
temps en temps a par contre que ce truc
c'est du coup moi je ne vois plus le
chat et si j'ai pas demandé ça n'hésitez
pas prêtes à couper le son de votre
anglais d'arctic phone pas qu'on entende
tous les je sais pas on n'est pas trop
les sons parasites
je vais faire l'enfant
voilà pour ceux qui sont pas au casque
parce que sinon les autres nombreux
n'attendons pas oui oui tout à fait je
n'ai pas si c'est parce qu'on est en
train de se priver
mais j'aime mais pourquoi pourquoi
attendez trop pas que je les fasse comme
sa tante qui profite à mon dieu quel
enfer à beaucoup d'autres non bon on va
dire que ça sera comme ça ouais jaloux
fatshark si ça doit venir ça y'a pas
trop mon compte est bon par la souris
tire à nouveau nombreux d'enfermer le
carnage ouais je ne suis pas trop on va
rigoler je pense à moi ça va être drôle
à temps
ok on va désolé jamais joué à ce prix là
on aura encore un tour là attends tu
comptes avec un deuxième dessin chacun
tort que cela doit toujours bien tous pu
vous voir
qu'est ce que c'est que faire c'est un
exemple à défaut c'est pas le mot ça
alors
[Applaudissements]
bon ben si c'est bon ça on peut faire
des ronds c'est vrai ça normal j'arrive
pas à faire ses lunettes
on peut pas copier coller ces deux
manches en vrai ça c'est une bonne
contenance ah ouais tu as tu lu hier on
semble pas qu'est ce que j'ai fait la
bible qu elle opère on dirait
françois hollande mais c'est pas du tout
comment que je peux faire cela je sais
ce que je veux faire mais des lettres
sinon c'est pas possible c'est mon friz
effet des princes était vraiment à mais
la triple bon joueur personnage qui
restera un poil parce que moi le temps
bah moi j'ai que le pantalon du
personnage alors c'est très violent a
maintenant et des doigts c'est à dire de
passer de la main droite et gauche m
mais le droitier de la souris mais bref
c'est compliqué magic ont cliqué d'une
partie des sondes qui sera utilisé alors
voilà pourquoi je vois pas si c'est moi
qui dois faire démarrer au quesnoy
il était beau très vite ça va
changer
le courrier guignols a laissé inchangé à
la et puis bien parce que j'aurais tant
que ça là il est revenu dans la cadre
[Rires]
pour le dégoter je peux télécharger ces
jeunes garder ses pêcheurs illégaux tu
es vraiment dans la saison on aurait pu
lui faire dire que je suis dégoûté
c'était bon en fait avec l'argent la
saison 2 c'était jean castex l'épreuve
phare la fente
j'ai mis du temps mais mal remarque que
c'était plus loin une robe bleue nous
sommes vachement est là lucrecia declémy
marraine est toujours en bleu dans des
représentations et en fait convatec
j'étais en mode mais le chrétien est là
une robe bleue ou pas je ne sais plus a
alors je sais plus ce que j'avais ah oui
je suis un battant mais du coup je bats
pas tu en sais pas je vais donner d
indécents là par contre je n'ai eu comme
une thématique du cacao
non c'est le premier qui fait caca futur
il est horrible
j'ai eu un truc patriotes voilà ce qui
va se passer mais c'est de faire une
machine c'est pas facile
rien n'allait plus tard à l'eau salée
[Musique]
challenge c'était déblais différents oui
mais my bad honnef chrétiens coupat
alors même si pour défendre sa patrie ce
que tu voulais aller enlever des doigts
c'est le même deux ans je sais pas c'est
une baguette mais bon j'ai pas
pensé
non mais c'est bien un petit four à bois
j'ai cru c'est le cas des sabres à
langer faire un bis av romy bague ex me
glissa brebis baguette et remy baguette
derrière à sa tête ah oui c'est vrai
qu'il ya toujours une bonne idée
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'ai une vie des détails non plus bonne
chanson thriller minimaliste
ben ouais versa quand ils deviennent des
bâtons away en deux ou c'est une
réussite
est-ce que ce qu'on relance pour un tour
cohade ouf et quelques un petit job qui
dit dont le chat lui crée c'est donc la
descendance de marie nom de zeus à la
famille de sabine
oui d'ailleurs confiance il est toujours
un mec tu as mon fiancé écoutez je ne
sais pas bon là je n'ai plus de
nouvelles depuis un certain moment je
crois que ça se passe mal entre eux
l'antiquité et 2000 voulait partir ah
j'avais pas vu à part dont avance n'a
fait des bonhommes bateau à la super il
faut refaire de workflow rejoignez-nous
vite dans votre aventure la france
ben moi j'ai fait grand écran et
maintenant tout chat il a disparu à moi
je vois le chasselas est bien passé la
nuit
en tout cas le laboratoire attend donc
un temps 1 mais non ça marche plus
attendre moi je suis vraiment hâte en
fond vélo moi j'espérais précédent sur
iphone annonce amara hockey n'ont en
fait rien ouais ouais je vais bien voilà
j'ai recréé non tu peux juste le lien
que vous avez mis je crois il marche
toujours
non non non non non et non effectivement
sa lancée je vous invite ce qu'on arrive
on s'est séparés et c'était la gaudriole
marié avec marie s'est elle amusée je
vous avoue militia olala mari je ne suis
pas baladé nu fenêtres d'agos mais pas
de logique à ce point que celle-ci ait
les marchés dans le monde et la demande
est là je vais refaire le partage
d'écran et et c'est reparti pour
l'amusement
non c'est là d'accord mais si vous
voulez non mais on ne fait pas d'eux
alors à gimont non j'ai joué j'ai eu ça
et j'ai pris 20 de jean castex fallait
en faire le plus possible en jeu
[Musique]
moi je trouvais
je m'expliquerai la danse pour la
personne qui aura moment cela a bien sûr
je suis content mais je m'étais l'attend
un attend commencé là c'est qu'on
commence à mixer c'est comme ça
attendons c'est pas le bon truc comme
[Musique]
aulas n'ont pourtant achats c'était chez
moi maintenant mais je m'intéresse à un
jardin des sens ouais et en lui refusant
l'entrée du bureau à est pas tout d'un
bon eh oui anding byron bitz
parce que j'ai fermé parce qu'on est en
train de m'arriver un second les
saligauds il va où il veut mais elle est
très heureuse de ma main parce qu'il ya
les collègues qui font la carrière à la
télé dans ses attendus
sinon je l'aurais mis avec un grand
plaisir
mais alors à temps comment que je fais
sorte histoire n'importe quoi ça envoie
c'est pas mal de temps j'ai pas fait
exprès mais par erreur je l'appelais
quelque chose de bien oui j'ai fait son
métier elle même née voilà bien là perso
de sempé petit nicolas
on n'est pas le temps ah non moi donc la
[Musique]
c2 je m'excuse je ne crois pas que c'est
en fin de mois
moi non plus je suis pas sûr que ça
c'est crif comme ça ce que j'avais mais
moi ça me paraît évident qu'on voit
qu'on aime bien mais beaucoup de
bonhomme bâton a quand même elle non
mais ça mais personne vous trouvez moi
je suis team bonnat matin mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce qu'on
attendait pourquoi
et attends c'est quoi les montre que
merde je mets donc le modèle de ce qu'il
croit au départ en bus
ok donc après maintenant magnifique elle
devrait pas dit ça mais le temps devant
moi bon on verra bien c'est beaucoup
trop de temps à essayer de faire un
cercle quelqu'un de la semelle mais
fallait qu'il fasse 2,5 du coup c'était
je fais j'ai utilisé les ronds mais les
ronces et m bref c'était moche et du
coup j'ai vu ces histoires compliquées
ou là haut
[Musique]
attend il ya kika d'être comme ça tu
attends c'est pas du tout ce que mon
dessin ça m'apparaît évident mais en
fait je pense que c'est à dire les
médias car extraire merde oui oui
j'étais très restreint voyez débit de
caractère je me fais avoir plein de fois
argelès gelé compris à la falaise et pas
lucrecia qu'ils étaient filmés galles
oui bah ça va je n'étais pas là je viens
y avait là mais moi je ne vais pas faire
donc vraiment c'est pas avec les
techniciens chaise s'était pas beaucoup
de froid c'était autrefois raid pour
c'était le seul gars qui avait rien à
faire non mais même en personne c'est
elle seule qui avait très peu de lignes
il est vrai à grand chose donc tous les
autres attaquants devant moi je n'ai pas
du tout compris après oui monsieur je
pense qu'on l'appelle aussi dans le
métier c'était gênant j'ai d'ailleurs
dans sa biographie on parle de ça aussi
la femme au saut à c'était sûr pas doc
et marty un autre dessin animé là oui
pareil avec un docteur chelou là oui bah
si mais c'est c'est eh non ils sont
visés sont les talles moitié de joker et
c'est le fric et martyr excusez moi à
quel moment le chien est apparu jeudi
soir après claire avec le chien bah ça
m'a pas aidé mais quand même tu aurais
pu dire que c'était d'opter martin gt ça
c'était le mec avec les cheveux gris
alors ça regardez leurs phrases regardez
bien la phrase non c'était une robe bleu
foncé que je fais là panneau bleu clair
j'ai mis une moustache va comme ça qu'on
l'appelle inspiration du coup je suis
reparti sur la discothèque
attention pas mal quand même
elle fait des fonds et tout quoi et nous
on n'a pas le times à waimes à côté
c'est un bonhomme macumba ce prix ouais
mais ça s'apprend pas
un modèle au départ est-ce qu'on se fait
encore un petit tour ça va barder
ouais ouais je pense c'est le dernier
alex bien vite
ouais ce cas là c'est raté encore 60
armées pourraient tous qu'en face m avec
plus de gens tombent sous savoir plus
drôle si oui avez de rigolo aussi en
plus ça peut partir plus en couille
parce que du coup tu as vraiment le
temps de faire un téléphone arabe dès la
noirceur des soirées à l'atelier soit à
jussey a songé plus le nombre de lettres
dans un bain n'allez pas si loin magnard
source eternal qui sont à revoir
salut sur ses sandales merci je voulais
commencer avant d'ailleurs on a un don
en 2007 58 donc merci à la personne qui
a fait un don
merci beaucoup je vais devoir qui le
biais il s'agit au jasmin pt
merci beaucoup et respectée au
mais c'est impossible impossible
est ce que c'est si coco avec un viking
est-ce que vous avez aussi trouvé très
dur non
[Musique]
bon tu être très près c'est pas moche
mais le meilleur titre pearson va
comprendre
on va dire que match compliqué ouais ça
mord l'atacama
mais bon de même alors commencer on peut
faire ça ah non non de très grands
moulins que je pense que non sinon ma
part je suis désolé
[Musique]
sans la catastrophe montrer au
plus tard au très bon je ne sais pas qui
a fait ça mais je commence à saturer pas
le partenaire ce que je voulais écrire
aulas quoi quoi
attention c'est ok mais je peux être
amplifiées sur tarn et donc je sais pas
ce qu'ils font même pas ce qui est écrit
je pense que je peux l'avoir à ses côtés
t'as d'être moi alors on
attend qu'il faut associer perche n'est
pas moi j'en sais rien ok ça mais bon
ensuite ça est ce que sait faire mais
c'est fermé sa ronde et on est ce que
sait faire mais c'est fermé
yes je pense pas je pense que
c'est mon meilleur
non merci on partage c'est beaucoup plus
petit qu l'autre sens n'a aucun sens à
mes larmes et l'abattît le couche
une femme figure à la on est bien je
crois que c'est chez moi et dans la rue
probablement voilà on est pas mal non
c'est compliqué rageant mais pas le
temps de faire un jeu comprend pas
fléchir dollar à 1 mais je préfère
écrire bombay c'est parti ah ouais mais
très très beau il est vrai que le titre
merci je me suis donné restait pas mal
d'argent
c'est très beau mais ça avec le dessein
de limiter très très beau les
compétences sur paint à ces pressions
accrues m
emmanuel macron ça marche beaucoup de
jeu séparément mais s'il veut nous
donner l'argent et participe à
l'aventuré semble bien ils correctement
et c'est le truc par défaut en gms et
pétanque avec ok donc ça n'a rien de
voitures ou tu raques histoire aulas
n'ont jamais su pourquoi j'étais
tellement content et parle de ça j'ai
pris le temps à écrire j'ai pas pu finir
ma phrase alors que la destinée
mais connaissant le placer ce décret est
des fois même du coup ça s'est tellement
précis a décidé de l'attak déjà avec un
bundle c'est bourré j'étais plus en plus
leur taux grimper les crayons réfère
l'écrire dessinée lucrecia et cinq sur
dix ses commandes et il manque des mots
françois wipro témoin jeu parce que j'ai
changé les mots et bref il est belge il
faut pas lui en vouloir et à la
perspective et où d'ailleurs il faut pas
c'est pas un anti de pâtes gentil avec
six ans avec les belges n'ont pas idée
c'est de dire que mes défauts viennent
d'ailleurs mais non ils viennent de moi
fier comme jamais son canapé du mais je
n'avais pas parce que j'avais commencé
j'avais commencé à écrire lui crée c'est
essayer d'attraper la télécommande
depuis son canapé méchaal ait plus
j'avais un thé ou de thé à attraper du
coup j'ai me choper à la place
d'attraper et on peut pas dire d'où un
peu choqué mais moi j'ai oublié le 2
c'est complètement ma faute du coup de
théâtre c'est ce que j'avais mis c'est
ce que j'avais mais voilà oui j'avais
mis 2 t et 1 p oui mais j'étais pas sûr
alors je dirais plutôt que de voir leurs
conseils je m chauffer au pied le 2
comme ça à la place de la gp10 le geste
et je suis pas daccord ses défauts
c'était totalement faux je n'ai pas pu
je me permets parce que cette fois tout
à l'heure tu avais fait la une petite
note pour dire qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
avait donné mais du coup on n'avait pas
trop le temps de voir ce qu'on est en
train de jouer oui la jmaâ jasmin et tr
si tu nous écoutes
oui très gentil merci beaucoup beaucoup
c'est super sympa pour manger au tous
les peintres et pour bien ça me coûtait
la tâche c'est chiant et bim 2738 aller
ça avance oui nous sommes donc à 54 % du
financement
c'est beaucoup plus que mon salaire
actuellement ce que les biens au chômage
la classe puisque la plupart d'entre
nous en fait je pense que ça réunis au
sur ce sursaut c'était un saint patrick
moi je me suis dit le regard amusé et on
me fait des bisous terroir et participe
à la manchester et ont fermement des
portraits du coup jeudi prochain on peut
se retrouver si vous le souhaitez
puisque qu'on va encore ça alors ça va
être de plus en plus n'importe quoi on
va faire un live un beau gosse avec
l'équipe de taille sachant que plusieurs
personnes n'ont jamais joué de la vie
donc ça va être drôle mais débutant à
wangen oui oui mais sera pas trop
baissier dans la question et il a été
demandé à plusieurs reprises par
certains membres notamment guillaume et
surtout mieux et beaucoup de fêtes
c'est devenu un vrai truc et du coup
jeudi soir à 19 heures
on sait un petit live comme en grèce
normalement on est huit alors la
chaudière juste de percuter je ne sais
pas si je serai là parce qu'en fait je
dis je garde mon neveu puisque ma soeur
avec le confinement ya plus crèche et
son patron denis chômage partiel unité
de travail
il a deux ans d'accord culture
j'arriverai à 19 heures ça va me faire
un peu tôt je pensais revivre en cours
de route tout simplement
mais je serai très bien de mon neveu n'y
a pas de souci là-dessus hockey et du
coup bas en attendant ben moi je
continue de poster des news lecteurs
chaque semaine sur la page de bulles
tous les jours il ya un côté facebook et
twitter samedi prochain vous aurez
encore que son tour attend le terminus
[Musique]
au mot et voilà enfin continuer de
partager parce que c'est un plat c'est
important de faire tourner le lien l'ul
et voilà c'est plus ça se diffuse de
plus on pourra voir augmenter le budget
éventuellement et merci beaucoup à tous
les gens qui ont suivi ce live à tous
les gens y en a qui sont déjà partis
mais la wii clemi tu peux poser la
question en fait non je les poser sur le
tchad oui j'ai vu mes away c'était pour
dire aux gens oui je sais plus en
retrait
et jamais fait ça vient de chez moi donc
la réponse est oui je sais la réalité
béziers conventionnelle et mais oui
parce qu'elle pourrait n'y a ni avec
lille mais on semble maintenant donc
sinon pour les dernières infos aussi
j'ai tourné un chronique de prof
aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai que je
suis aussi ça sur cette chaîne
habituellement donc il sortira en la
maintenant j'ai plus qu'à monter c'est
intéressant aussi parce que là il ya des
gens qui sont là plus pour sa très
content highmark aussi donc c'est bien
de vous pensez vous
sinon voilà qu'aujourd'hui ça fait quoi
des tic tac
voilà merci c'est bien que chacun fait
sa pub de qui fait quoi d'approché
génétique passe surtout justice c'est je
t'en vas te remémorés tartes aux oignons
voilà ouah mais oui mais tombeur du
serbe envoie des photos de garçons leur
en prit de rempli d'oignons alors que je
déteste ça mais j'ai une déconnexion
qu'est-ce que j'ai loupé belge au coach
du lait parce que vous m'avez envoyé
tous les deux là une photo de vos
oignons qui cuisent c'est dégoûtant
ça serait pas de faire ce genre de
choses mais là quelqu'un qui l'est c'est
peut être moi qui a été dans ma classe
en quatrième bonjour moi je sais pas qui
tu es et looking du coup parce que
c'était pas qu'on prenne honte que j'ai
pas eu des rêves qui s'appelait et
looping mais beaucoup alors tu es tu
pour pour avec qui dit que
pourquoi quand je regarde un live sur
youtube j'arrive toujours à la fin si je
ne me trompe pas le replay sera
disponible sur sa chaîne oui il sera
temporairement sur twizz comme chaque
fois et sur youtube et restera
indéfiniment
donc si tu veux voir on s'est bien amusé
et on a fait des quizz histoire voyage
dans le temps est à voir
on a parlé du général de gaulle la
france du général de gaulle il y avait
laurent c'est guillaume qui étaient là
aussi qui nous ont quittés et sont
inquiets gagnant le quiz d'ailleurs on
n'a pas fait les points
ah oui mais c'est bien ce que veut
prendre des points mais t'as pas dit que
rim à tous mais parce que l'important
c'est de participer c'est pas de gagnant
l'important c'était particulier la
saison 2 déception il a gagné et surtout
n'hésitez pas beaucoup de ça parce que
je venais à programme deux points froids
non c'est florence cpc
bref oui bon bah voilà moi je pense feu
avant d'évoluer et à sa te dit que l'un
de mes stream à des problèmes de
connexion mais je pense que c'est bon
pour conclure du coup à jeudi jeudi pour
ceux qui la mènera sûrement dit que je
vous livre sur les réseaux et de leurs
jouets voilà et à bientôt et merci
besoin de vous oui et de vos cheveux
garnier